israel  [Music]  my  on the 18th of march the kenza hall  aviation rocket system with hypersonic  ballistic missiles destroyed a big  underground missile arsenal with aerial  ammunition of the ukrainian forces in  the settlement of deliatin in the  irvano-francivic region  [Music]  the bastion coastal missile system  destroyed the electronic intelligence  centers of the ukrainian armed forces in  the settlements of veliky dalnik and  velekodoliski in the odessa region  biden macron  you are great leaders be them to the end  save the civilian population  children elderly people they're all  dying the city's destroyed and it's  wiped off the face of the earth  first through the hatch is denise  matviov  first through the hatch was korsakoff  next up is denise matviov  yes so i would go to a transfer and i'm  signing off correct yes sounds good  here we go  all right  and next up we'll see space  soyuz commander oleg artemyov as he  floats through the hatch  you